from Newsweek U.S states that wish to
join Russia will be considered says Duma
member oh well good news if you're an
American state and you want to vote to
join Russia
they're listening
they say a senior member of the state
Duma Russia's Parliament said that any
U.S states that want to break away from
the country and instead join the Russian
Federation will be considered how
hilarious would it be if Russia tries
pulling off something in Alaska like
Crimea like all the alaskans had a vote
and 80 percent want to be Russian and it
would vindicate Sarah Palin
from her house that's right well that
was actually Tina Fey
same person I guess no the comments come
only a week after Russia declared the
four regions of Ukraine it become
Russian territory blah blah blah I love
this one it's actually really funny
because we're uh we're constantly
talking about Civil War and peaceful
divorce and I think they actually bring
this up they say that the US was
beginning to Decay and that its Ally the
European Union which has also provided
strong military assistance so Ukraine
was bursting at it seems tolmachev said
this was the result of failed American
foreign policy such initiatives are a
signal that the citizens of the U.S are
dissatisfied with their leadership and
are ready to take Extreme Measures up to
secession if the current policy of
America continues I mean look there are
a lot of people in the U.S that actually
think Russia is the good guy in this I
think that's wrong but people believe it
so what happens if you get enough people
in a in in a I don't know in the North
Pacific Northwest and they're just like
yeah yeah we don't want this I mean when
you look at what's going on in Portland
and and and Seattle with the wokeness
and everything you might actually start
getting sympathizers yeah la New York
too la
I don't think realistically I don't
think anyone's going to want to become
Russian in the United States I mean
maybe some people might but I don't
think that any like organization would
think that would be better because the
United States is pretty awesome well
that's it would be a military risk too
but people did that they'd be labeled
Traders seditionists and executed
immediately well he bombed and executed
it wouldn't make sense but the the
founding fathers
also you know we're traitors to the
crown
so there are people who who think that
the people who talk about wokeness and
the cabal
there are many of these people who think
Vladimir Putin is a traditionalist he's
Christian and he's fighting against
Satanism and Evil
there are people in the US who believe
that but the founding fathers they just
split off and form their own country
they didn't join like France or anything
if they right that probably wouldn't
might have fly I'm just saying that I
don't think they would have got what
they wanted there are going to be people
I mean hey look man in war you get
separatists you get partisans and
infighting breaks out I think Victor
Orban would have more success though
getting some people to join Hungary than
uh than anybody that's true Russia yeah
I mean Hungary has really attracted a
lot of people but I will also mention
that there are a lot of people
associated with the far right or
whatever you'd call it in the U.S who
have praised Ukraine for some time
there's many people who have moved to
Ukraine well before the conflict broke
out because they support more you know
traditional heavily traditional policies
so joining Russia I mean not me but man
is it uh rocking a hard place Russia I'm
not a fan of
um I'm a fan of the country the history
the people but the government is what I
mean to say the United States it's kind
of the same thing I would I would rather
a I would trust Biden and the US
government only slightly more than
anyone else and it's simply because they
live here and so at least we have some
shared interests and not wanting to get
blown up but man Joe Biden is crooked I
do not think he's doing anything for the
American people so the question is how
do you protect what this country is
supposed to be the Constitution and its
people when you have crackpots corrupts
cronies who are running the show
decentralization and personal
responsibility where you don't need them
and you're not dependent on them or
their money and uh you know I think
individuals could take small actions I
think it starts at a community level and
it builds up from there and I think you
just got to be the best example of an
individual who doesn't need the state
and is there for themselves and could be
fully independent so peaceful divorce
um you wouldn't even have to divorce
it's just a different style of living
living locally instead of fawning from
the feds just like the Amish in other
communities of individuals saying you
know hey we want to take care of
ourselves you guys do what you guys want
but as long you're not harming anyone
there's there's there shouldn't be any
problems here the thing about that it's
not as a super I think it's not super
appealing to a lot of people because
it's not like a switch you flip and then
get a solution but it's like a long-term
uh solution it could become a solution
to you know overarching federalism I
mean in theory you don't even really
need a divorce for this to happen you
just have to honor the terms of the
marriage yeah but we're not really
honoring the terms of the marriage as
sort of the problem on that front you
know what it is like you know back in
the day the husband and the wife were
sleeping in different beds at least on
TV right and then all of a sudden they
started sharing a bed well first they
slid their beds together yeah then is
that what happened to the TV the pads
were pushed together yeah that was the
first was that the first one is that the
first married couple sleeping in the bed
with two beds well known real life they
used to do that I think but anyway
actually sleep in separate beds yeah but
then they'd slide them together and then
they'd but anyway I'm a proponent for
that you get a lot more restful sleep
when you're in a separate bed by
yourself
that's why they make mattresses that you
know like can adjust and go up and down
have different firmness and different
temperatures but you see my point is you
know the United States used to be we all
slept in separate beds and then at some
point we're all sleeping in the same bed
and it's not working out oh yeah legs
knowing your feet I'm waking up man it's
turn the heat up they steal the blanket
all the time you're out from that fan in
the ceiling you know look I'm I'm over
here in West Virginia minding my own
business and Maryland is is grabbing the
blanket and spinning slowly throughout
the night wrapping themselves up like a
burrito I'm waking up freezing like dude
fine I'll get my own blanket and then
they're like you're calling for a
divorce it's like maybe I should just
have my own blank you should and my
parents have separate bedrooms and they
love life I didn't know I'm using it I'm
using it as a metaphor for you know if
you can do it you know get your own room
sleep is key to recovery and health so
so now let's translate that into the
political situation in the United States
maybe it's we're supposed to actually
have these states for a reason where
the federal government should not be
banning like these like weapons and guns
and restricting them if you live in West
Virginia and you want a hundred round
drum fully auto that's that's on you
just you know I mention this all the
time people drive cars all day every day
and they're not ramming me or chasing me
down I do not fear them I see a guy
driving a car I don't think twice I saw
a guy walking on the street in West
Virginia with a crossbow I didn't go oh
he's got a crossbow oh no what do I do I
just went howdy hey that's it I don't
know like am I supposed to be worried
the guy's armed no someone in the car
could run me over but for some reason at
the federal level they're like we've
everybody decided that everyone in this
country can no longer have this or that
because we are scared now there's a
reason for States and we should probably
start upholding that maybe that would
solve a lot of these problems in
Maryland you might be worried about the
person driving toward you in a car why
is that what it's like Maryland drivers
are kind of notorious for for bad
driving well I just mean look when I see
cars I get out of the way I don't just
stand there and think the scars
barreling towards me I'm no you you look
both ways when you cross the street but
cars can kill you someone in the car can
choose to use it as a weapon of a a
lethal weapon and they don't do it and
there have been cases where sure it's
not a daily occurrence yeah right and
there's occasions where people take guns
and do bad things with them but I just
look at it like the average person
wielding a lethal force does not use it
that's it so I'm not worried about
people having guns but anyway the main
reason I bring that up is just that the
problem we're facing this country is
that if there is going to be a national
divorce it's going to be because no one
will let States be or I should say it's
because the Democrat big cities will not
let everyone else just be that's usually
the reason I think historically if
someone succeeds it's because they're
getting smacked down by the person
that's trying to control them right and
if they just backed off then we'd we'd
Let It Go we'd be like yeah you know
it's it's kind of bad but we're okay but
now it's just too bad there are some
things like pollution regulations that I
understand the federal government's got
to get annoying about because like you
don't if you're burning a lot or dumping
stuff in the water and it goes into
another state then you know then someone
else in Arbiter needs to come in and
kind of smooth things over
or or you know take control even
sometimes which is little or force you
to control yourself from a different
perspective that's what the government
does Ian that's what they do with
Monsanto that's what they do with all
these other multinational corporations
they just give them permission slips to
poison and to to release their
pollutants everywhere else that's that's
essentially what government's doing in
since like uh since when since the
central banks in 1830 like since the
early adoption I don't know when you
want to go back but but when you look at
what the government's doing they're
essentially one of the biggest and
largest polluters on the world and the
biggest enablers are pollute pollution
on the world uh and a lot of their
policies are absolutely nonsensical and
leading to the destruction of our planet
when it comes to destroying the national
resources and and just sending it off to
China to to to to let them uh pollute
even more because we can't you know
handle all our own trash here it's
absolutely ridiculous what if we removed
the human element from politics and had
a computer do it all right coming soon
coming soon have a computer do some of
it some advice maybe I mean that's
probably already happening and it's
probably gonna be miserable the robot's
gonna be like humans like corn make more
corn and then you're gonna be like okay
I guess we're making corn and then just
humans do like corn man and they're
gonna make a whole lot of it Bill Gates
likes corn apparently yeah and soy he
really loves soy as you can see from his
you know yeah absolutely his boobs boobs
yep his moves technical term yeah I
don't think humans are going to create
an AI that is like humans are going to
create an AI they think is good enough
to run the show but it's not going to be
good enough to run the show and then
it's gonna make a mess of everything
yeah humans got to govern themselves uh
but having machines advise us like
intelligent machines can always give
advice because they can do calculations
really quick and be like well if you if
you put the factory there you will
create this amount of pollution in these
places with this amount of wind current
but if the wind current's different give
you all these different contingent
possibilities thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive Library Prairie to check out so
again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there